et mokhtar autant son ami hatem ben arfa
et carly zen autant mokhtar c'est une
autre ambiance
[Musique]
oh
donc je te présente julien mouche a
piqué les mois on chantait des
photographes
depuis il avait atteint lundi soir du
coup qui m'a contacté je la prochaine
fois je le vois mais il va appeler aux 3
4 jo écart qu'à un truc éventuellement
nous proposer oui alors avec lequel tu
es d'accord a priori voilà d'après moi
je fais moi je fais des dessins de
paparazzo siège de la presse people en
soirée et ma charge de ce truc d'autres
par contre
j'écoute voir du coup j'en étais été un
peu chaud pour faire d une sorte de
fausse paparazzade
mais après ça peut être intéressant pour
et se faire de l'argent et on pourra
faire une sorte de mini scénarios entre
guillemets mais de paparazzi un peu gens
ont sorti de soirée un petit bisou dans
la dent là où dans la rue un truc où tu
pourrait statuer sur sur son it bag
équipe à tous les deux un filet d'eau
je peux faire ça et là bon là c'est un
peu un peu peut-être beaucoup pour toi
mais mais il ya 50 1000e aux francas ce
serait une sorte de forme en forme de
sextape la sextape vidéos et des photos
on peut tirer d'un truc comme s'ils
savaient comment avoir une serviette
oui comme un roman photo et voilà en
gros
taf et jean il m'a dit que ce serait
quelque chose pour faire ce n'est pas
pour le sma qui est ce que c'est normal
mais juste le smac la même touche touche
majuscule kg de famille il ya vraiment
du lit fasse faire pour le coup c'est du
cash fascination chez moi 5000 je peux
même négociations à six en 1910 bon j'ai
passé l'âge je veux jouer et j'aime bien
ça me va c'est pas du vent dans photo
après butin non non non ce sera pas levé
avant bien sûr mais ça doit être un
commun accord
je prends une petite photo l'agencement
du bruit je connais pas je me vois pas
quitter
moi je m'en fou ce que tu veux compléter
l'accord de principe je peux pas je peux
pas sortir sans mauvaise soirée n'est
plus moi comment mais aussi faire en
sorte que son support à temps alors moi
je peux faire un truc si je te sors sans
eux après on le garde jean et moi j'en
fais comme ça sans prendre je veux pas
de nausées et bien tu vas me dire comme
un nom et participeront à 150 me c'est
une foule de ce paquebot
moi je vais en faire tous les jours mais
après en plus intense et toujours par
mois les smac 15 secondes balles et puis
si tu respectes fait les photos quand tu
te rappelles toi en forme pour faire
parce que si moi j'essaie de faire
croquer les copains
sur la série je ne peux pas chris brown
sur le sujet ils vont toujours et
associe son genre primo le principe de
jeunes pattes c'est une voiture
bon c'est pas qu'ils sont principe de la
fin de match était l'étude c'est bon
quoi tu as raison il est incertain
aujourd'hui les choses se produisent
chaque année des étiquettes on nous
bloque alors petit resto je me sens et
que la france mais ils veulent et 5000
en amont du tour de saumur je t'achète
il me dit mais moi comme il s'est donné
pour jouer aux boules de 800 mg zéro
il fait gratuit je voyais meubles et je
n'ai rien à dire à 0 qu'ils sont montrés
tellement pas montré présent par les a
pas vus battre le monde patauge c'est
une potacherie 1 c'est un montage à la
cour touche les lieux où ce nom
[Applaudissements]
c'est une bombe à ces boues ne fait que
ça est ce que tu crois que dans la north
cuche est juste lassé des menaces
j'aime bien manger bien entendu j'ai
bien entendu il a vécu ma mère tu es qu
est ce que tu prends vraiment que ça
c'est dit finalement prêt c'est que ces
forces toucher un peu cette chose qui
parle de fusée je peux t'exprimer du
tout la vase est revenu à temps
je peux texan je n'ai rien à voir je
tenais à gagner cette mauvaise deux
attentats du coup c'est très content de
montrer deux ans et ça ça va suffire
comme ça mais c'est pas je vais pas le
diffuser ou non mais là ils ont du mal à
les trucs à chercher mon iphone mais si
tu veux je suis comme ça une provision
sociaux prendre si on se moque un thème
si on shoote l'intérieur
bravo star un bateau
[Applaudissements]